here's a unique award and to present it
the beautiful star of the smart which
will soon be buzzing its way to your
neighborhood hive she's a very special
lady who have long worship from afar she
insisted on it the winner of two Academy
Awards she was the memorable Melanie of
Gone with the Wind and will be admired
forever as Olivia de Havilland
the Board of Governors has voted an
honorary award to a lady named Maggie
who started sixty-two years ago from
negative cutter for DW Griffith to
supervising editor or Neil Simon's
goodbye girl she has run a lot of
celluloid through her moviola
she has been
she has been wet-nurse nanny surgeon
Guardian and court of last resort for
many a problem picture her unmistakable
imprint is on scores of features
bridging the history of movies from
orphans of the storm to the sunshine
boys and so we are honored to recognize
an almost unparalleled record by an
editor a force forever young one of our
very own Maggie Margaret
I'm deeply grateful I want to thank the
board of directors of the Academy for
giving me this wonderful award and also
the producers and directors who wrote
the two marvellous letters that
contributed toward the award I'm deeply
grateful but isn't it wonderful one can
win an award for something one loves to
do and I love my work and thanks to Ray
Stark I'm still doing it
thank you